we're going to go straight to the US
Secretary of State who's in the US
departing for Israel right now he was
speaking moments ago to the press as he
embarks on a new on the ground round of
diplomacy this is Anthony blinkin good
afternoon everyone uh we are uh heading
back to the Middle East heading to
Israel uh heading to Jordan with three
principal goals in mind first uh to talk
to uh the Israeli government about the
ongoing campaign against the Hamas
terrorist
organization as uh we've said from the
start Israel has not only the right but
the obligation to defend itself and also
to take steps to try to make sure that
this never happens again we've also said
very clearly and repeatedly that how
Israel does this matters uh we will
focus as well on steps that need to be
taken uh to protect civilians who are in
a crossfire of of hamas's making uh and
we want to look look at concrete steps
that could be taken to better protect
them um we've seen in recent days
Palestinian civilians continuing to Bear
the brunt of this uh this action uh and
it's important that the United States is
committed to making sure everything
possible is done to protect
civilians um at the same time we're
determined that this conflict not spread
and we'll be talking to both the Israeli
government and partners in the region
uh about what all of us are doing to
prevent that from happening second big
objective of course is to continue our
efforts to get humanitarian assistance
in uh and to get our citizens and
Nationals out of Gaza in terms of
humanitarian assistance going in uh
we've been able to establish over the
last couple of weeks um efforts to get
trucks moving we've had about 50 to 60
trucks a day of assistance going in we
need that and want that to increase and
I expect you'll see that uh in the
coming days at the same time we've been
working to make sure that our Nationals
and other foreign Nationals could get
out and over the last two days you've
seen Americans and their families begin
to come out of Gaza uh and we expect
that to continue over the coming days
this has been uh a very deliberate
effort on our part working with other
countries to make sure we could get
passage out for our citizens and
citizens from other countries uh of
course we're intensely focused every
single day on the hostages and taking
every possible step that we can uh in
concert with others uh to secure their
release third and finally uh we will be
talking about how we can set the
conditions for a durable sustainable
peace durable sustainable security for
Israelis and Palestinians alike um we're
focused on the day of we also uh need to
be focused on the day after and so in
conversations that U will be be having
through the course of this this weekend
uh I expect you'll see a focus there and
particularly how we can get over time to
two states for two peoples which in our
judgment Remains the best guarantor and
maybe the only guarantor of a secure
Jewish and Democratic Israel and uh
Palestinians with the state uh that
they're entitled to so these will be the
uh the things that were're focused on um
these are challenging times um these are
intensely difficult issues but I am
convinced that American diplomacy can
make a difference in moving everyone to
a better place that's what we'll be
working to
do questions thank you thank you Mr
secretary do you assess that Israel has
shown restraint up to this point in
their offensive in Gaza and what are the
concrete steps you'll be pushing them on
and are you confident that you'll
actually be able to get them to make any
movement on this given the maximalist
positions we've seen from Israeli well
as we said and it's and it's important
um Israel has the right and the
obligation to defend itself and again to
try to make sure that what happened
never happens again no country no
country not the United States not anyone
else that I can think of would tolerate
uh the slaughter of its civilians so we
stand behind that uh we stand behind the
proposition but as democracies um the
United States Israel other democracies
have a responsibility to do everything
possible to protect civilians who may be
caught in In Harm's Way and this again
is a is a crossfire quite literally of
Hamas is making the fact that it
cynically and
monstrously deliberately has people uh
men women and children as human Shields
um puts uh puts its uh command posts
puts its leadership puts its Fighters
puts its weapons putes Munitions
underneath hospitals or even inside them
schools mosques makes this incredibly
challenging but we have to rise to that
responsibility and so we will be talking
about concrete steps uh that can and
should be taken to minimize harm to men
women and children uh in uh in Gaza uh
and this is something that the United
States is committed to I'm not going to
get into the the details here but it's
very much uh on the agenda when I see a
Palestinian child a boy a girl
pulled from the rubble of a collapsed
building that hits me in the gut as much
as seeing a child in Israel or anywhere
else uh so this is something that we
have an obligation uh to respond to and
we
will thank you um I wonder if you could
get your assessment of the the current
risk of the spillover and the conflict
uh today Hezbollah said they've attacked
19 posts along Israel's border with
Lebanon uh the houth said the other day
they're entering the conflict and just
secondly while you're in the region uh
how do you expect to be able to get
other countries in the region involved
in uh sort of the day after plan that
you're talking about when uh you know
there's Rising opposition Rising protest
against Israel from we've seen Bahrain
and jordanians pull out their
ambassadors so we are determined to
prevent escalation on on any of these
fronts whether it's um Lebanon Northern
Israel Southern Lebanon uh whether it's
the West Bank whether it's anywhere else
in the region and the president's been
very clear in what he said publicly
we've been very clear in what we've
shared privately we've been very clear
in some of the actions we're taking that
we are determined to deter uh any
escalation so with our partners um as
well we're making sure that that message
gets through it's not in anyone's
interest not in anyone's interest for
this to escalate and I think some of the
uh other parties involved actually
recognize that but we're going to work
on that every single day you assess that
that's that's happening though the
strikes already already taking place you
know uh what we've seen so far uh are
yet discreet uh attacks we've responded
as uh as necessary including on our
forces uh our forces who are in the
region in Syria and Iraq uh to prevent
the Resurgence of of isol which also
should be in everyone's interest and you
saw the actions that we took in response
to that but as I said we're determined
to uh prevent escalation to prevent the
spread of this conflict uh and we're
taking the uh necessary steps to try to
make sure that that happens with regard
to um uh to what comes next again I
think understandably people are very
focused on the day of uh not just the uh
the day after but we do have to have
conversations now about how we can best
set the conditions for a durable
sustainable peace durable sustainable
security for Israelis and Palestinians
alike uh so I expect that uh those are
conversations that we'll have an
opportunity to pursue uh over the next
couple of days but uh this is a a
long-term term effort but we have to
make sure that we're focused on it now
thanks thanks
everyone you have just been listening to
the US Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin he's just about to board his
plane currently in the US will be in
Israel by tomorrow so another round of
diplomacy for America's top Diplomat he
will be meeting with the Israeli leaders
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin uh
Netanyahu but also uh meeting other
leaders in the region I want to bring in
Mike Hannah in Washington DC Mike we've
both been listening to what blinkin had
to say I'd like to go um through the
three the three priorities for the us as
blinkin embarks on this on this new
visit to Israel and other countries
number one he said was Israel has a
right and obligation to defend itself
but how it does so matter so the US
appears to be uh appears to be treading
this this rather fine line now about yes
Israel can can can conduct and prosecute
this war in Gaza but it shouldn't kill
too many
civilians yeah certainly that is
something that we heard there from the
Secretary of State let me just uh say
something that has just come out of the
White House here President Biden has
been meeting with the president of the
Dominican Republic and in response to
shouted questions afterwards President
Biden said that 74 dual American
Palestinian citizens have been moved out
of the Gaza Strip that is assumed over
the border into Egypt but to return to
the Secretary of State there a wide
ranging news conference on his way to
Israel making very clear and this is the
first time that a Us official has
actually brought this up since this
conflict began that the time has come as
well to start talking about an end game
or a post end game to start talking
about conditions for a lasting peace now
this is something that the secretary of
state says he will be discussing in
coming days in uh Israel in his meetings
there also speaking as well about the
need for civilians to be protected
saying that civilians are being caught
in this ongoing conflict and they have
to be protected the need for
humanitarian Aid is utterly intense then
we've also been hearing from White House
officials about the fact that the
secretary of state will be pressing the
Israeli Prime Minister for what are dis
described as brief cessations of
hostilities these are brief humanitarian
pauses as the officials are saying which
would allow first of all captives to be
removed out and also for humanitarian
supplies to be moved in the official
saying this will all be determined by
duration how long will these pauses last
and location where will the pauses
happen so this a kind of targeted series
of humanitarian pauses what the US is
eyeing out and which it will be
discussing the secretary of state will
be discussing with the Israeli Prime
Minister in the days ahead look you
mentioned the day after right which is
what Anthony blinkin was talking about
people are focused on the day of which
is the fighting now and the war as it's
being conducted but we also have to talk
with the Israelis tomorrow this is
blinkin speaking about the day after how
there can be a durable peace and durable
security and Palestinians I believe he
said the estate that Palestinians
deserve to live in is there this I mean
this is a you this is a really broad
principle he gave no details is there a
plan in place do we know anything more
about American diplomacy on this or what
they might be saying to Israel
about achieving durable peace after this
war well throughout this conflict apart
from the initial week when the
statements of the Biden administration
were purely ones of support for Israel
what emerged in subsequent days is a
more nuanced reaction in terms of what
is going on and what we heard now from
the Secretary of State is concrete
measures aimed at as he puts it the day
after now throughout the recent weeks
we've heard from the bided
Administration that key to this is the
two-state solution this has been the
Mantra of the bided Administration which
it now wants to revisit uh the Secretary
of State making very clear that the
framework within which any lasting peace
will happen has to be within the context
of a two-state solution now very
interesting that the Biden ad
Administration and the Secretary of
State are choosing to talk about this
now they appear to be moving beyond the
immediate conflict to try and look at
what is the end game what happens if or
when the conflict uh halts or ceases or
is suspended for a period of time all of
these factors we do not know where it is
going what we do know is we've heard a
reiteration of the fundamental Biden
Administration policy that any lasting
peace if it is to be secured uh after
this conflict is ended must be based on
the two-state solution all right Mike
Hannah reporting uh from the White House
in Washington DC I want to recap what
we've heard because we've heard from the
White House we also have news from
Anthony blinkin you see his plane
leaving there that was just moments ago
um so the recap is this from the White
House we just found out from Joe Biden
who was answering a shouted question
that 74 Palestinian Americans have left
the Gaza Strip now 74 pales Americans
have left the Gaza Strip remember
yesterday and today uh the Rua uh border
crossing opened to let people out both
people who were critically injured
severely wounded and people who were
dual Nationals that's one thing the
other is what we just heard from Anthony
blinkin these pictures there that you're
seeing are from maybe about five minutes
ago now he said essentially three things
this as he heads to Israel on his latest
diplomatic tour he said that the he's
going to talk to Israel about how they
are conducting the a war against Hamas
because in his opinion they have a duty
and an obligation to defend themselves
but the way they do so must minimize
civilian casualties that was one the
second objective for the us on this trip
is to get more humanitarian Aid into the
Gaza Strip and more Americans and other
Nationals so dual Nationals out of the
Gaza Strip number three as we were just
discussing with uh Mike Hannah there is
that the Americans also want to talk
about a durable peace and about a
Palestinian State What blinkin refers to
as the day
after so that's what we heard from
America's Top
diplomat